ils l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 422 de monsieur philippe
bas à monsieur le ministre de l'écologie
du développement durable et de l'énergie
monsieur le ministre le département de
la manche apporte depuis de nombreuses
années une contribution décisive à la
politique énergétique de la france
c'est le cas avec l'usiné de
retraitement de la hague des déchets
nucléaires
c'est le cas avec la centrale nucléaire
de flamanville c'est le cas aussi avec
le futur réacteur p r qui est en cours
de construction à flamanville même mais
c'est aussi le cas pour demain avec l
implantation sur le port de cherbourg
d'une partie de la filière industrielle
de création des éoliennes en mer et des
hydroliennes
il ya donc un contraste assez saisissant
entre cette capacité de production
d'énergie électrique que nous avons
développé sur ce territoire et la
qualité de la distribution du courant
électrique sur le même territoire
nous avons eu au mois de mars dernier
une panne de courant électrique qui a
affecté pendant plusieurs jours 43 mille
de nos concitoyens à la suite d'un
épisode neigeux et il est évident que
l'épisode neigeux n'est pas le seul
responsable de cette panne s'est
largement à cause de la médiocre qualité
de l'équipement de distribution
d'électricité et de transport
d'électricité que cette panne a pu avoir
de telles de tels effets vous savez que
en france nous n'avons enfoui qu'à peu
près la moitié de ce qui est enfoui dans
les pays comme l'angleterre l'allemagne
ou l'europe du nord en termes de lignes
à haute tension et à moyenne tension a
comme le disent les techniciens et dans
le département de la manche nous sommes
à la moitié du chiffre national
c'est-à-dire au quart de ce qui se passe
dans les pays les plus avancés dans ce
domaine et ma question est donc simple
du point de vue de la qualité du courant
de la sécurité de sa fourniture le
gouvernement entend t-il
donné les instructions nécessaires pour
que nous puissions moderniser notre
système de transport du courant
électrique en particulier dans la manche
mais ça ma question vaut aussi au plan
national
je pense à la manche en particulier dont
je suis bien sûr l'élu parce que cet
écart que nous pouvons observer entre
les forts de ce département pour la
politique énergétique nationale et la
qualité de la distribution du courant
dans le même département fini par
exaspérer un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens de la manche merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à monsieur
philippe martin ministre de l'écologie
du développement durable et de l'énergie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'abord permettez moi de vous
dire combien je suis heureux de vous
retrouver en me rappelant d'une visite
ministérielle effectué dans le
département du gers il ya quelques
années de cela et où nous avions apporté
des éléments importants sur des
établissements de santé d'accueil de
personnes âgées
vous évoquez les conséquences de
l'épisode neigeux exceptionnel qui a
frappé le département de la manche en
mars dernier où je le rappelle la
vigilance rouge avait été déclenchée ce
qui était une première pour le
département de la manche
vous avez raison de dire qu'il y à des
coupures d'électricité très importante
et je tiens d'abord ici vous comprendrez
a salué l' extrême mobilisation des
agents de erdf qui avait que le soutien
des moyens de l'état de l'armée est
aussi parfois des retraités de ces
grandes entreprises ont mis tout en
oeuvre pour réparer au plus vite les
lignes électronique endommagé la
fourniture en électricité est une
mission de service public et
l'électricité est un service essentiel à
la vie quotidienne l activité économique
c'est pourquoi au-delà de la gestion de
crise due au phénomène métérologique
l'amélioration de la qualité de la
fourniture en électricité demeure une
action prioritaire des pouvoirs publics
celle ci passe par l'entretien et la
modernisation des réseaux de
distribution et se mesure d'abord par la
réduction des temps de coupure
ceux ci ont été stabilisés en 2010 et
sont d'environ 60 minutes en moyenne
annuelle
hors événements bien sûr exceptionnel
seule l'allemagne fait mieux en europe
pour des pays de taille comparable
mais faut-il le rappeler pour un coût de
distribution bien supérieur
la qualité de la fourniture en
électricité c'est aussi l'enfouissement
des réseaux vous en avez parlé de
moyenne tension qui permet de diminuer
l'impact paysager et la sensibilité du
réseau aux aléas climatiques
mon département il ya ont connu la
tempête klaus en sait quelque chose pour
d'autres évènements que des événements
neigeux à la à cette fin erdf a pris
deux engagements construire plus de 90%
des nouvelles lignes à moyenne tension
techniques souterraines à compter de
2005 et enfouir plus de 30000 km de
réseau en moyenne tension en dix ans
dans le cadre de son plan d'action aléas
climatiques de 2006
cet engagement a permis de relever le
ratio national réseau souterrain sur un
total du réseau de 32 % en 2000 et 43 8%
fin 2012
précisons cependant que l'enfouissement
systématique des lignes n'a pas
forcément synonyme d'amélioration de la
qualité de fourniture pour la moyenne
tension notamment le taux d'incidents
hors événements climatiques est en effet
à peu près identique pour les réseaux
aériens et les réseaux souterrains
ensuite l'enfouissement systématique
présente vous le savez des coûts élevés
et des difficultés techniques comme la
sensibilité aux inondations aux
variations de température au risque
d'accrochage des câbles lors des travaux
de terrassement dans le département de
la manche le ratio réseau souterrain sur
total du réseau pour la moyenne tension
est relativement faible vous l'avez dit
puisqu'il n'est que de 23 25 27 % en
tout cas le quart c'est pourquoi
l'effort d'investissement de erdf
il est plus important qu'ailleurs avec
une croissance de 20 % par an entre 2007
et 2010 soit un rythme de plus du double
de la moyenne nationale
j'ajoute que grâce aux mesures
d'accompagnement la construction de la
ligne à très haute tension
cotentin-maine 163 km de lignes
existantes doivent être mise en
souterrain dont 117 km de lignes
aériennes à basse et moyenne tension
surplombant les surfaces agricoles ainsi
que 268 km de lignes à construire ses
projets d'enfouissement de réseaux
électriques sont éligibles au crédit de
plan d'accompagnement du projet doté de
plus de 6 millions d'euros au bénéfice
des communes de la manche sur le tracé
de la ligne cotentin maine
merci monsieur ben merci monsieur le
ministre
ces engagements que vous avez rappelé je
souhaite qu'il soit encore amplifié
compte tenu du retard important qui est
accumulée dans ce département de la
manche qui vous l'avez rappelé et ça
s'ajoute à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur l'importance de la
production électrique manchoise pour le
reste du territoire national est un
département qui était déjà traversé par
une ligne à très haute tension et qui
est désormais de traversée par une
seconde ligne à très haute tension
c'est-à-dire deux balafres dans nos
paysages ce qui a suscité naturellement
les oppositions que vous pouvez imaginer
donc ça n'est que justice qu'à
l'occasion du passage de cette ligne à
très haute tension erdf puisse décider
d'installer des lignes enfouies
mon souhait est que on allait plus loin
que ce qui a déjà été prévue dans ce
domaine et puisque vous avez eu
l'amabilité de rappeler mon déplacement
dans le gers et les efforts sur le plan
des établissements de santé et médico
sociaux qui s'y sont développées je
serais ravi que vous puissiez me rendre
la visite que je vous ai fait en venant
dans la manche pour nous annoncer de
nouvelles mesures en faveur de la
fourniture d'électricité